(music and applause)
- Hi, everybody.
Hi, Kelly Clarkson.
- Hi, Rosie.
- How are you? I haven't
seen you in 20 years.
- I, I'm literally so excited about this.
I am disappointed in myself
'cause you know how in your show
you have the thing to come out
for people with short legs--
- Yes.
- That was one of my favorite
things about your show
'cause I'm so short and I-
we need to work on that.
- Yeah. Yeah. It was a good thing.
Although, once William Shatner was there
and it malfunctioned, and
his feet were, I guess,
not touching and all of
a sudden he slid down
right out of the chair on live TV.
- Well that's kind of funny as well.
- Yeah, it's funny for a
moment, but I was worried.
He's an elder gentleman, you know.
I thought, "There goes
William Shatner's back."
I just killed William Shatner.
- That's amazing.
- Which you don't wanna do.
- We haven't seen each other, though-
you said, "in 20 years."
- Right.
- I don't know if you remember,
but we were on The Tonight Show.
- Of course I remember, yes.
- Okay, 'cause I was, I
actually went back and looked
at the interview cause I was, like, I know
we ran into each other,
but I was so annoying
because I was nervous.
- [Rosie] No, no.
- But I was so nervous 'cause I'm such a--
Look at my smile, I'm so excited.
(Rosie laughs)
Like, I literally, like,
every time someone says--
'cause I never thought
I'd have a TV show--
but it was interesting-
I connected with you.
And you're such a fan of things.
- [Rosie] Yes.
- And you're, like, a true fan.
Like, I'm hoping to,
like, emulate that a bit.
So I'm--
- Well you did say to me, I
don't know if you remember,
you said, "I hope to
have a career like you."
- I did, I did.
- You did say that to me.
- But what's funny is, I
didn't mean, like, a talk show.
- Right.
- I meant longevity.
- Yeah, I was- yeah, I was--
I didn't even mean that, so.
- And I said to you,
you're gonna. I know it.
- I know.
- And here you are.
- I know, thank you, Nostradamus.
- You're welcome. It was me.
- Yeah (Kelly laughs).